oh hi it's still 2009 this is still game
life and i am still chris kohler you
know 2008 was not the best year for wii
owners who enjoy traditional games but
2009 could be better especially if we
get to play some of the games that are
already out in japan tatsunoko vs capcom
as you might have already guessed is the
long-awaited next entry in Capcom's vs.
series which pits the company's stable
of fighting game characters against
other companies superheroes the gameplay
style is like street fighter on
performance-enhancing drugs characters
can jump incredibly high do screen
filling super moves and generally cause
non-stop chaos you'll recognize the
street fighter characters of course but
unless you grew up watching Japanese
Saturday morning TV you're probably not
going to recognize a lot of the
characters from the top sunoco animation
studio which makes up the other half of
the lineup um maybe you know gatchaman
or tech a man or a yacht mmm no not
ringing any bells well who cares if you
want you can always just ignore them
completely and play as Capcom's
characters there's street fighters there
is beautiful Joe there's the guy from
Onimusha and even roll the housekeeping
robot for megaman the vs. games have
always been popular in the US and this
one seems to be pressing fans buttons
just the same as the classics I
certainly think it's fun so will it come
to America that could be tough
considering it's filled with licensed
characters that we've never heard of
tatsunoko vs capcom might be destined to
live in japan forever which would be a
shame the wii is home to a wide variety
of very simple games and let's tap by
sega is probably the simplest of them
all you don't even touch the Wii Remote
you put it on one end of this tap box
included with the game and then you tap
the other end to make it vibrate
so is this a gimmick yeah 100% it is but
it's funny because it actually works you
can tap the box to navigate the games
menu and then you can DoubleTap to pick
the game you want to play there are five
different minigames in lex tab in tap
runner you tap the box lightly with your
fingertips to make your little person
run and black the Box hard to make them
jump over hurdles and gaps for rhythm
tap you tap the box to the rhythm of a
song for some no suit kappa lightly and
for some you hit it harder silent blocks
is like playing Jenga you tap the blocks
in a stack as gently as you can to nudge
them out of the tower without collapsing
it bubble Voyager is a lot like the
classic NES game balloon fight you tap
the box to float your heavily armed
robot ninja along and avoid danger and
hit it harder to fire missiles and the
visualizer mode features a variety of
different interactive toys like
fireworks or paint splotches that appear
as you tap the box let's tap is a pretty
simple game once the gimmick of tapping
a box wears off I'm not really sure why
you want to keep playing it so of course
it probably has the best chance of any
of these games to get released here in
America this aster day of crisis is a
really unique game it's a realistic
action-packed disaster movie of a game
that looks like a hardcore game but
actually features casual accessible
gameplay it's for Wii owners who are
looking for this sort of pick up and
play game that doesn't have a cartoony
atmosphere this sort of person may not
actually exist which might explain
Nintendo's reluctance to bring disaster
to the US but it's pretty fun you play
as Raymond Bryce an emergency rescue
worker who's having the worst day of his
life as natural disasters erupt all over
the place you have to rescue people by
dragging them to safety or from more
precarious predicaments
you'll also get shot at a lot and at
this point the game jumps into a
first-person like gun style shooting
mode it's kind of like virtue of pop you
move around automatically while you just
concentrate on seeing off the bad guys
sometimes you'll have to wave the
wiimote and nunchuck furiously to escape
incoming disasters like crumbling
ceilings during an earthquake disaster
was designed to resemble a classic
Hollywood disaster movie to the extent
that all the voice acting in this
Japanese game is in English and it's not
that much worse than most other video
games hey attention you might learn
something so as you can see it wouldn't
be that difficult to bring disaster day
of crisis to the United States it it's
an alright game but you know the cameras
a little janky the graphics are not so
hot um so while I enjoyed playing it I
wouldn't be too upset if it didn't come
to the u.s. either